merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ravi de vous savoir toujours
parmi nous grâce à qui nous l' alerté le
n'est pas à l'ordre du jour dit le
président monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues non je savais manuel
Vali est parti
précipitamment vous présentez
aujourd'hui un texte visant à instaurer
un pass Navigo unique au tarif des zones
1 et 2 proposition se heurte
malheureusement à un problème de taille
le coût évidemment en matière de
mobilité les bonnes intentions pourrait
nous inviter à proposer des transports
publics gratuits pour tous mais vous le
savez sur cette question comme sur tant
d'autres la gratuité n'existe pas le
coût est simplement transféré sur des
acteurs moins identifiables que l'usager
qui achète un ticket ou une carte
d'abonnement la réponse qu'apporte ce
texte à la question du financement passe
ainsi par l'augmentation du versement
transport cette charge qui pèse sur les
entreprises représente environ 3,2
milliards d'euros pour
2012 soit quasiment l'équivalent des
recettes tarifaires de la RATP et de la
SNCF en Île-de-France qui sont de 3,3
milliards d'euros en 2011 si on ajoute à
ce montant le coût de remboursement de
la moitié du passe Navigo des salariés
environ 800 millions d'euros par an la
contribution des entreprises au
financement des transports en commun
sera de l'ordre de 4 milliards d'euros
en 2012 soit pratiquement la moitié du
coût de fonctionnement des transports en
commun
francilien mes chers collègues
j'interviens aujourd'hui en tant qu'élu
parisien soucieux de l'échelle du Grand
Paris soucieux de ne pas avoir à se voir
déliter le Réseau des entreprises qui
contribuent à la création de richesses
franhilienne et qui sont une maille très
importante de notre territoire le
contexte économique a imposé à de
nombreuses entreprises de réduire la
voilure pour ne pas succomber aux effets
de la crise il est aujourd'hui
impensable de porter un coût
supplémentaire à cette situation très
difficile en alourdissant le poids des
charges qui pèse sur
l'activité pourtant la mise en œuvre
d'une tarification unique du Pass Navigo
devrait avoir un coût osillant entre 550
et 700 millions d'euros par an sur la
base d'un forfait de 6 5 € par mois pour
les abonnements Navigo et d'une
diminution du prix des billets longue
distance l'équilibre de cette mesure est
établi à 91 € par mois selon le STIF
cette mesure pourrait être financée par
l'application d'un taux unifié à 2,6 %
du versement transport cette
harmonisation impacte très fortement des
départements comme la scinene saintn ou
le valde mararne dont le taux
augmenterait de 1,7 et
2,6 et les quatre départements de la
grande couronne de
1,4 à
2,6 cette opération représente ainsi un
surcût net pour les entreprises qui
s'élèvent à 586 millions d'euros soit
près de 25 % en une seule année mes
chers collègues nous avons le devoir de
préserver le tissu entrepreneurial
franilien notre énergie doit s'orienter
vers la création de richesse qui assure
la prospérité de tous et le financement
des services publics de qualité si les
entreprises disparaissent c'est l'emploi
qui disparaît et sans emploi la question
du passe Navigo unique devient
malheureusement très accessoire par
ailleurs je tiens à formuler une
inquiétude qui concerne spécifiquement
les usagers parisiens les entreprise ne
pouvant indéfiniment être sollicité il
est à craindre que le coût de cette
harmonisation se reporte un jour une
fois de plus sur les usagers parisiens
qui ont déjà vu considérablement
augmenter le prix de leur abonnement
depuis plusieurs
années cette situation serait tout à
fait fâcheuse les Parisiens n'ayant pas
vocation à subventionner les transports
de ceux qui ont fait le choix de
s'éloigner de la capitale certaines
familles pour vivre à Paris doivent
s'acquitter de loyers très
haut leur demander de financer le coût
de long trajet de l'île-de-fance
reviendrait une forme de double peine un
loyer cher et des transports de plus en
plus coûteux mes chers collèguesattend
les usagers avant le tarif unique c'est
un service de qualité c'est de pouvoir
voyager en sécurité dans des trains qui
arrivent à l'heure cette proposition
crée finalement un problème de
financement quand il faudrait en réalité
trouver des solutions d'organisation et
de service c'est pourquoi mes chers
collègues le groupe um ne votera pas ce
texte je vous remercie merci chers
collègues